if there is a pandemic or a catastrophe
with a weather the the rules can be
changed you were so desperate to win
weren't you
every politician who is looking for for
a success is desperate to win yes the EU
Commission says the new law undermines
the judicial independence of Polish
judges this is double standards I can
bet that President Duda will be
reelected despite the corona virus
pandemic Poland's government pushed hard
for a presidential election this month
in the expectation that it would win but
the opposition forced a last-minute
delay my guest this week from Poland is
Dominik tart in ski Polish MEP from the
ruling law and justice party was his
government guilty of trying to put
politics ahead of people's lives
[Music]
Dominic Kaczynski welcome to conflict
zone thank you for having me let's go
back to the beginning of this month when
your party was still hoping to hold a
presidential election Donald Tusk former
prime minister of Poland said that only
a madman or a criminal would proceed
with an election during an international
health crisis but you didn't care about
the risks to people did you you expected
to win and that was all that mattered
are you trying to say that Donald Tusk
called people from Germany Bavaria and
from Switzerland and from southern Korea
and mad people because these are the
places where elections took place maybe
he's calling Americans a mad people as
they are having their primaries now so
we we resigned from this idea of
elections at the moment but the language
Donald Tusk is using is unacceptable
well you didn't exactly get the support
of the National Electoral Commission did
you poland's commissioner for human
rights of rice not surprised but you
didn't get it the European part and old
look the Organization for Security and
Cooperation in Europe they all told you
to postpone and all were ignored some
fifty countries around the world have
postponed during the pandemic and that's
what and that's this this is what we
this is what we decided that's number
one but the question is why Donald Tusk
is asking for for postponing elections
because their candidate X candidate it's
already changed she she was having a 5%
of support when our president and our
candidate at the moment is having 63 so
I'm not surprised that they are running
away they are just a political cowards
and they trying to well escape from from
this catastrophe which is just in front
of them the fact is though you were
prepared to take a risk right through
March April and into May itself with the
health of your people you were so
desperate to win weren't you
ha every politician who cares about his
country every politician who's looking
for for a success is desperate to and
yes we are desperate to win but we are
not desperate to hold the elections for
any price that's why this is the past
and we changed our mind we are we are
just observing the the whole situation
and and that's why the elections did not
took place so this is what the
opposition was asking for isn't it it
was a big risk because under your
party's rule Poland's Health Service is
hardly the envy of the EU is it but this
but this but this elections did not take
place so I'm surprised we are discussing
the past and the facts we did not cheat
place right up until the last moment you
were prepared to take that gamble that's
my point your health service luckily
wasn't strained but it's not in the best
of states is it in Poland well what we
it's not a gamble it's Constitution if
if Constitution is very clear about our
responsibility for the country we have
to we have to deal with the situation
and this is this is what we this is what
our government is doing no one was ready
for this kind of pandemic III can't
really remember from the history that
this kind of pandemic as this Chinese
virus took place ever so this is unusual
and we have to find ourselves in this
situation and be responsible for the
constitution for the country that's why
first of all our our our term was was
changed and now that the elections
probably will take place in beginning of
July maybe you talked about the
Constitution but you tried in the last
moments of April and May to hold a
postal vote the Constitution says
changes can't be made to the electoral
law or less than six months before an
election can they so you were quite
happy to ignore what the tests that you
have said no not a Constitution but the
the tribunal court was very clear about
the changes and it's very clear with
with one of the points that in pandemic
times is very clear in Polish law the
the changes can be made just before the
election this is what we found out our
government was was had to deal with the
pandemic so so if there is a pandemic or
catastrophe with a where're the the
rules can be changed we haven't changed
it even though even though it's it's
allowed we you also had some warning
shots fired at you by the Catholic
Church that your party always claims to
Revere that the bishops warned about
possible violations of the
constitutional order and the need to
preserve the principles of free and fair
elections that's just about as close as
the church comes to issuing a formal
rebuke to a ruling political party isn't
it the funny thing is that when we are
trying to talk about abortion which is
killing the babies the church is
criticized by many mainly media when
Church is taking a voice about the
elections which is catastrophe for the
opposition then the the church is the
one who should be mentioned we are
sovereign government we are Catholics we
hear all the voices and we listen to the
people also to the bishops but it's us
our Prime Minister and our president who
are making decisions when the bishops
drew attention to the need for free and
fair elections
perhaps they were also referring to the
huge sums of public money that your
government dropped into the coffers of
the state media which have more or less
become your party's own PR agency
haven't they about certainly concerned
20 of people
I am the best example of people from the
public media I used to work the media I
used to be director we've got 16
branches of national television in
Poland I was I was in charge of one of
them and I was fired by previous
government just because I was
conservative I was I wasn't I wasn't a
member of any
political party and they did suck me
just they throw me away just ten days
after they took power so if you're
asking about the PR agency and political
tools in the media I am the living
example how the previous government was
treating people you wouldn't be happy if
someone would treat you in this way
believe me
well let's stay with the the present
government because in January the
president who's from your party signed a
bill giving more than five hundred
million dollars to fund radio and
television outlets that have been giving
him hugely supportive coverage during
his campaign for re-election how fair is
that it's not about president it's not
about one political party
it's about our mission I know what the
mission is in the public media how many
public the state televisions is in
Germany we've got only one and and this
is nothing unusual that government is
paying for for the public media that's
how it was that's how it is and that's
how it's gonna be in the future the
state media is supposed to be neutral
and you gave them a blatant deny what it
is - because they were helping your
campaign your election campaign but the
public cares public money is part of the
public of the budget of the government
and the public media our finances by the
budget since they won since 1990 or even
before that it's nothing unusual nothing
new and this this is the money which is
paid every single year I can't see the
controversy in here that's that's our
duty as a government to pay for the
public services like health media or
anything else so they the public money
is supposed to fund a public media that
is doing your bidding and providing
support for your view it's not true what
happened to the new tribe well reporters
without borders
reporters without borders called
Poland's public media dropp'd baldest
mouthpieces propaganda mouthpieces that
tolerate neither opposition nor
neutrality from employees
and fire those who refuse to comply it's
a striking resemblance to the old
frosting the operator all this all these
organizations international
organizations which are attacking Poland
Hungary United States
I mean mr. Trump they are using their
position for the political goals and I
know it's it's just political I I can't
really see their reason to to even
comment these attacks on Hungary Poland
and mr. Trump mainly at the moment it's
just not true let's talk about the
courts because Freedom House said you
were trying to convert the judiciary
into a client political tool but you
don't like talking about so we we did it
or we tried it you're trying to do it
you're trying to the European Commission
infringement procedure against your
government for your latest attempt to
put the judges and the [ __ ] control
hasn't it we are having a drunk-driving
judges we are having judges from the
martial law times and we have many many
of those which you don't have from the
Communist stands because most of the
countries was did not suffer as as we
did so we have to clean it up to be
straight this is what we promised this
is our government was elected and I
don't see the reason we should resign
from that and and obviously whatever we
would try to do they would attack us
saying that this is political decision
but you have to remember that one day
our party will lose election and judges
courts will stay so another party will
be happy to have political courts it's
just not true well the latest move by
the European Commission follows the
passing of what the opposition calls
your muzzle law which can be used to
find or even sack judges who questioned
the government's legal reforms isn't it
incredible you put your judges on the
lead and you tell them when and when
they can't when they can speak and when
they can't the
okay I am a member of the European
Parliament can I be put in jail can I be
charged yes I can I can lose my immunity
I can and then the prosecutor can charge
me with with whatever if I'm drunk
driving or or stealing something do you
know that you are judges in Poland up
till now
cannot be charged for whatever they do
if they if they drunk driving stealing
and we've got videos of the of the
charges were stealing money in the shop
he couldn't be charged do you think it's
okay when we are talking about the
balance of powers three powers why they
should be above law above the
politicians it's just not right you want
all those powers don't you executive
legislative judicial you want them all
in your hands and the EU Commission says
your númenor muscles is what you think
they they they say the EU Commission
says the new law undermines the judicial
independence of Polish judges it's not
just their view it's the Venice
Commission NGOs human rights groups the
Parliamentary Assembly of the Council of
Europe are they all wrong have they all
misunderstood Poland poor pop yes but
they are all wrong that that's correct
yes that's what I think they're not
wrong mainly this is political debate
this is not about the rule of law this
is not about the Constitution this is
about Hungary and Poland
and mr. Trump this is what they do this
is double standards well we're just
talking about the punishment the
malleable standards the outgoing
president of your Supreme Court
malgorzata gasthof accused you of trying
to accumulate excessive power she said
for the last five years all the power
has been in the hands of the ruling
party who set the goal of destroying the
independence of the court and she said
it was the judges duties daav is the
person who was taking who was taking a
part of the protests political protest
of Polish opposition they are not
allowed to be active politically and
that was political activity she was she
was marching on the streets of Warsaw
with a candle
happy to support Polish opposition that
was against the Polish law that was
political activity with a Civic Platform
and the rest is this okay is this right
do you think that that's how judges
should be active do you she said it was
the judges duty to speak out they took
an oath to guard the law out of cold to
our dude every judge about the clean up
the post-communist courts really that's
it to clean up yes when they are active
politically if they did if they disagree
with with current government they trying
to call it a duty when we are doing what
Polish people expect this is not
democracy unconstitutional violation of
the Human Rights decent debt so they can
call it duty when they are when they are
active politically and we are and we are
breaking the law is that right it's just
it's just it's just silly everyone knows
this is about about their seats about
politics about power and about money in
the government white paper that you put
out in 2018 giving the reasons for what
you called reforms of the judiciary you
did say the judges had never accounted
for their communist past and those
reasons simply what that reason simply
wasn't true was it because 81% of
members of the Supreme Court were
replaced in 1990 under the illustration
laws in 1997 42 judges and 21 family
members of deceased what about 19% of
those who left what about this 19 post
the post communist judges who left who
are still judging and their original
apart obviously as you well know they
were individual oh you said they did
nothing about the colonies I'm pointing
out to you that they did what I'm trying
to say there's only one judge who can
put you in jail and if we if we have
those who are a part of this communist
machine which was as you know communism
was
much worse than the new fascists it's
just just against our dignity as a
nation they shouldn't be there not even
one not 19 percent not 10% not one not
even one shouldn't be in the court and
we're gonna clean up the courts this is
what we promised to the Polish people it
does what our government was elected the
truth is that the courts have just got
in the way of what you wanted to do
wasn't it in 2016 your party leader
Yaroslav Kachinsky it's not a fact
it's opinion now he said he said in 2016
changes to the constitutional court were
necessary to ensure there were no legal
blocks on government policies aimed at
creating a fairer economy no legal
blocks on government bonds so basically
you want to rule without any legal
checks and balances whatsoever don't you
and you shut up the judges if they
criticize no no no no you send checks
and balances as you call it it's
completely different we had it we had a
cases when we tried to change the the
courts and they were protesting against
the law so it's different when someone
is locking up the doors of the public
place like like a court that's what we
had and there is a difference when
someone is trying to discuss it debate
it in a parliament it's unacceptable we
are we are free democratic country and
no one can rule the country if it's if
it's not not elected they want to be a
politicians they are unelected but they
want to rule the country this was
protesting because they don't trust your
government that's why they were
protesting okay so if if people do not
trust our government watch my lips
they wanna bet who's gonna win next
election presidential and parliamentary
can you see the can you see the polls
now and the support we are having in
from around the country I can bet that
President Duda will be reelected this
stuff as some of the other measures that
your government has been taking not just
against the court but
you've been doing a lot of social Angela
it's not against courts
it's against post communist at the
communists judges it's completely
different
not all judges not the courts be
specific but central people in the rest
of the world plenty of organizations
respected organizations don't buy that
line mister mister touching ski as you
well know you well a Polish pop but but
Polish people not buying but supporting
us this is why our government was
elected second time it's gonna be
elected third time I'm 100% sure
whatever my most important is what
people's people nation is what people
post people are saying not organization
mainly from Soros I don't care about
Soros I care or care about polls let's
look at the social engineering you've
been trying trying to row back LGBT
rights in Poland in a pretty direct
assault assault last year and I'll
rights not right it's not true again
it's not about LGBT rights everyone is
equal in Poland everyone's three this is
democratic country it's about pushing
promoting and using money for the
organizations with the flags of the
rainbow they are making money on it they
want to get into the schools and the
children it's not about rights they can
they can do whatever I don't care how
they sleep how they live they are free
but when they are using public money and
this is what is happening now in war so
it's just not right now when the
pro-government newspaper Gazeta Posca
distributed stickers to advertise LGBT
free zones in Poland you're quite happy
with that level of discrimination LGBT
ideology God's very important they said
LGBT three free zones that's what the
stickers which were distributed by
Gazeta polska actually said and the EU
Commission universal for that kind of
discrimination you didn't speak out
about it did you so it's not it's it's
it's not true it's about ideology which
is pushed by a very very small group of
the politicians who are trying to use
gbt who are trying to say that we are
racist anti-semitic and all this all
that we've been called names for so many
years again I don't care and I'm trying
to tell you and repeat it everyone in
Poland is free come for a weekend it's a
beautiful country safe country you can
come and see we haven't had even one
terrorist attack because our policy of
the illegal migration so this is what
I'm trying to repeat it every single
time
Poland is safe clean and beautiful come
and see safe for women in 2016 your
party toys or any idea your party toyed
with the idea of withdrawing from the
Council of Europe Convention on
preventing and combating violence
against women your reasons that the
treaty endangered the family and
promoted gender ideology how exactly
this cracking down on violence against
women endanger the family it has nothing
to do about it it has nothing to do
about women it has nothing to do about
violation it's about declaration I was
the member of the Council of Europe I
was even in charge of the Polish
delegation to the Council of Europe and
I had a chance twice to discuss it
it's not about women it's about this
thing it's about the illegal migration
and Sharia law we had this discussion
officially with a legal committee to
debating a Sharia law in Europe when no
one is discussing European values in
Saudi Arabia or any other Sharia law
states so we are trying to keep Europe
keep Poland great and Christian well you
know in 2017 your president simply
instructed people not to implement the
convention that was supposed to combat
violence against women he said regarding
national laws on violence against women
those laws already in place in Poland
are working and being enforced that
wasn't true was it that's simply not
true the figures don't bear that out the
law is not working first of all if first
of all do you have a date
about the violence against women and men
do you have a data yes yes your police
data for 2017 excited so in their 92
thousand cases of family violence in
which women amounted to nearly 73
percent of the victims and men were the
perpetrators in 92 percent of cases so
how could your party possibly claim that
laws were in place working to protect
women they weren't these are your
figures your police pick when when I
when I see what when we see what is
going on in the Malmo
in Sweden when we see what's going on in
love Paris when you see data from all
this places around European Union you
can tell that were that this law works
in Poland how many dedicated shelters
does Poland have for women and children
who survived domestic violence how many
hundreds hundreds like everyone else in
Europe one shelter 126 bed shelter in
the whole that's not true as Robert
Osborne I'm a Roman Catholic I'm a Roman
Catholic and I know how many shelters
are organized by by church church itself
not not by the government it's it's
hundreds of this places and I've been
there many times in many of them in 2016
the year after your party took power
your own supreme audit office called
services for survivors of violence
insufficient and highlighted the
scarcity of shelter spaces for them that
your own supreme ordered ordered office
are they wrong do you think it's good
that we are trying to improve the
conditions do you think it's good why
are you trying to improve the conditions
there's no evidence that you are you're
defending women's rights group or that
right and center who try to protect
women you've defunded half a dozen of
them at least of course of course we are
we are funding places which are helping
it's not about shelters only but also
psychology psychologists and those who
are helping to basically raise the kids
it's it's common sense and it's obvious
everyone knows that that if there is
anyone who needs help
this help will begin attaching ski
thanks very much for being on conflict
zone
[Music]
you